We're almost at the end of staging at Airbnb
RV here on the farm,
and we have one more thing that we need to get done.
Um, we had a.
We actually got a free pillow set with the.
Already came with the mattress,
and we upgraded the mattress.
So I thought, why not upgrade the pillows too, because
it's hot balls in here.
We don't have the air conditioning on yet.
Still waiting for the wiring to be wired up.
But we're gonna be in here for a few minutes
just checking out, um,
the pillows that arrived today.
So we needed to upgrade the pillows
as along with the mattress,
we did get free pillows with the RV,
but they were like these weird,
cheapest, like,
display pillows I've ever seen.
So I thought,
why not go on TikTok shop
and look to see if there's any pillows on there.
So in there.
Like, they must be compressed in there,
cause this is two queen pillows inside here.
So like, yeah,
this is a small box,
a vacuum seal.
Um, kinda break the vacuum.
Oh, breeze open some windows.
That feels nice.
It was like freezing.
Now we have this warm front come through.
I know, it's so hot in here.
I have the heat on here
in here and I will save it.
And now it's hot. Okay,
these are the three pillows that I got with the RV.
They're like,
like little bit of foam
mixed With the polyester lumpy.
And that's not gonna be satisfying to like to,
I guess. Here it feels.
It feels like down.
Very nice and soft.
Pillow is nice and soft.
It's hundred percent cotton
and the inside is a polyester gel.
It feels so soft and like form fitting.
And see, it just bounces right back.
Definitely an upgrade compared to the.
The cheap, this clay pillows we got for free.
Nothing. Spray on this one.